I knew from game is some of the best
news we can here at this channel I want
to take a look at the new teaser and try
to focus on only what we can really can
creat Li learn from it
I could speculate wildly about this
being a continuation of Fromm's past
games or hidden lower connections to the
souls born but I'm going to leave that
up to the other guys
mostly Miyazaki has made it clear that
from is making new things so let's go
into this with that mindset starts with
the fade in from black drums sounds of
stormy weather a fire crackle and a
flute like wind instrument plays there
seem to be a lot of Eastern or oriental
themes to this teaser which we'll see
more of later on so this could mean that
the drums could be taiko drums a very
pronounced distinctive performance style
of Japanese percussion the wind 'red
cement doesn't quite sound like a
western flute to me again more Eastern
maybe like a bamboo fie this is a bit of
an odd connection but compare the
instrumental sounds in the teaser with
this snippet of the original Naruto
opening
[Music]
obviously there are large thematic
differences but the drums sound pretty
similar and the flutes especially do
what really makes me think they're
essentially the same is that before
major notes there's a small lead-up to
reach the notes in both instances that
is a really unique feature not found in
most other instruments so this leads me
to believe that these are some
significant hints towards Chinese
Japanese or Eastern in general themes
and possibly a setting of such the storm
sounds and small crackling fire arcing
back to what we're familiar with in the
sold born franchise of a dark setting
offset by moments of comfort and respite
in the form of bonfires that's something
we're fairly familiar with except the
possibility of rain and thunderstorms
does show a bit of something new as
those aren't very typical in souls born
let's stop the lane and get into the
meat of this twelve second long teaser
we open on quite an odd blood and bone
mechanism over a table or manuscript of
writing in order we see the bone handle
piece turn the rope go taut and the
coiled rope at Center tightens and turns
as it continues to tighten the mechanism
or tool or whatever it is starts to
shake with tension it's being tight into
its absolute max as this happens we hear
what sounds like an Eastern string
instrument maybe guzheng I don't know
I'm super immersed in Asian instruments
and the pronunciation of that instrument
it matches the dissonance of the
mechanism stressing under its immense
tension it is not too pleasant for Sam
and then nothing blackness and the
tagline shadows die twice I'll come back
to this as there's a lot we just passed
over so the mechanism has a bone arm a
bloody rope and what looks like post
sixteenth-century metal parts it's
really hard to say what it is it could
be a tool or a weapon some have said
like the trick weapons from blood-borne
and to be honest we have seen a lot of
normal tools used as weapons before so I
think classifying it as either isn't too
big a deal it definitely has the dark
death based themes that from has become
familiar with the tool weapon isn't in
too great of condition the bone isn't
clean or polished it looks like it's
covered in dirt and cuts the string is
pretty scraggly and frayed and the metal
is unpolished tarnished
this all points to a kind of decayed
states of the materials which is really
something that's expected from from soft
at this point the only thing left to
really bring up in this tool weapon is
what looks like a kunai or a Japanese
throwing knife stuck in the middle of
the rope this again pushes the Eastern
setting but also further strengthens the
possible weapon combat focus of the game
especially having a weapon embedded
within a tool like this the kunai could
possibly be at the end of the rope
the Rope is being tightened so it might
let out in a rapid fashion expelling
all that energy at once there have been
suggestions that this could be a proto
grappling hook which the kunai and rope
do lends some credence to but it would
be unfair to completely rule out the
possibility of this still being a weapon
could even be both and either way this
is something that seems to lead us down
a road of significant movement change
when compared to souls born a grappling
hook used to propel yourself or bring an
enemy closer could really expand our
options to explore and survive in
whatever world we find ourselves in in
this game it really expands mobility it
looks like some kind of steampunk ninja
tool for fighting and utility or easily
both that about wraps up the main weapon
tool for ground now for the background
the most prominent feature is the
stretching wall or manuscript containing
what looks like some calligraphy of
either kanji or another Eastern script
written vertically as is often the case
with certain Eastern scripts once again
Eastern setting so I think it's fairly
confirmed that we're getting a setting
or at least significant influence of
Eastern culture here what's also
interesting is that this feature isn't
being respected at all the table wall
whatever it is is covered in burn marks
shavings debris and what appears to be
chisel sticking in it these in the small
fire in the corner gives a bit of a
workshop feel we could be seen the
finishing touches of craftsmen finishing
his work finalizing this tool or weapon
and even if this is the case the tool
weapon still looks a bit too CREP it as
we said earlier the materials are frayed
and very unpolished even this world's
craftsman doesn't have the resources to
make actually new clean weapons or tools
this isn't too big a shocker as they
used a bone as one of the main pieces
for the tool weapon and lastly the
tagline shadows died twice got a couple
of thoughts on this
shadows could mean ninjas as we've
already seen a couple pointers in that
direction and shadow is a term very
fitting of a ninja often depicted in
black and acting in and from the shadows
an appropriate and fairly common moniker
die twice makes me think of the souls
mechanic of one death loses your souls
or XP temporarily and two deaths without
retrieving your souls permanently loses
them could be letting us know that this
mechanic is returning but there is
definitely more to it than that however
whatever that is I can't really surmise
as I don't have anything else to go off
of and wild speculation wouldn't really
help us lastly there had been some
comparisons to the font choice of these
words as similar to that of blood-borne
and they do look pretty similar past
that I don't really have a whole lot
though so we've gone through the whole
teaser what can we now conclude from it
I have a couple things
the familiar from soft themes of
darkness and severity are present in
spades and the Oasis feeling that
bonfires brought also appears to be back
there is significant eastern influence
and could easily be the setting of the
game a focus on tool weapons possibly
similar to blood-borne trick weapons or
maybe more of a utility focus like
something in the sense of a grappling
hook and ninjas I think this gives a bit
of a clearer picture of what to expect
from this game could it be blood-borne
too sure but I'm thinking it's something
new and also Sony's name is in plaster
all over this definitely more
interesting than code Bane in my opinion
hope some of what I've said has gotten
you thinking as there's a lot to think
about concerning this one and that I've
contributed some original thought to
this because I'm sure there are gonna be
tons of videos about this I'll surely
have more out as firm releases more info
and this game currently looks like quite
an interesting one thanks for watching
see you later peace
you